(chiming tone)
Joe is back,
and we're gonna turn our attention in this next presentation
on issues related to musculoskeletal health
as we look at some issues related specifically
to sports medicine.
Thank you, Joe. Take it away, sir.
We're gonna move through really a bulk of medical issues
that are related to sports medicine and athlete
that you need to be aware of,
and a few musculoskeletal issues in this section.
So let's get started right away.
You have the preparticipation exam.
That's where we start in sports medicine.
You know what the primary objectives are.
We wanna screen individuals
for factors that may predispose them
or be life-threatening or disabling to them.
Pay attention to the fact that the AMA has called out twice
for us to use the preparticipation exam
since these are primarily healthy kids
to have discussions about health related topics,
particularly risk taking behaviors,
smoking, drinking, drugs, sex, okay?
So that has shown up repeatedly on the exam,
the AMA's call to us to utilize the preparticipation exam
in this manner.
When we look at the preparticipation exam,
we restrict athletes for certain reasons.
A little over half of those are for musculoskeletal reasons.
A little under half are for medical reasons.
The greatest bulk of medical reasons
are due to cardiovascular related issues.
Elevated blood pressure
is the most common cardiovascular abnormality
found on the preparticipation exam.
I'm going to give you, as I have, lots of most common.
Those are things that I really want you
to remember over the course of this.
So what does Choosing Wisely tell us?
Don't screen for testicular cancer or inguinal hernias
in asymptomatic adolescent or adult patients, okay?
That answers a question that I'm commonly asked about.
And here are your clinical recommendations
for the preparticipation exam.
We're gonna talk about number one in a little more detail.
How do we screen for cardiovascular disease
and that risk for cardiac sudden death,
or CSD as we refer to it.
Athletes who have blood pressures under 160/100
should not be restricted.
Let them go on and play.
We start that the activity alone is partial treatment
for their elevated blood pressure,
or their hypertension as it may be,
but we can work that up as they are participating.
Also, individuals who have well-controlled asthma,
they can participate without any restriction.
And lastly, for our general high school athletes
outside of the NCAA,
outside of Olympic or pre-Olympic sports
or private organizations,
there are no screening blood or urine tests for individuals,
for asymptomatic individuals.
So if you're asked about a screening test,
no, we don't utilize screening tests
simply because they're getting a preparticipation exam.
So here's the next big question.
Do I obtain a screening ECG
for athletes undergoing their preparticipation exam?
How many say yes? How many say no?
Okay, well, this'll be fast then.
Let's jump through this, right?
We use the 14-point American Heart Association scale
that covers some personal history, some family history,
and then our physical exam.
Those are the 14 points.
I do not get a screening ECG, not in the United States.
If I have a positive response
anywhere on the 14-point checklist,
then it's up to my discretion
as to whether or not I want to obtain an ECG.
That's the answer.
Now, where do I find
this 14-point American Heart Association checklist?
Because I don't keep it every time a student comes in
for a preparticipation exam.
I don't know where it is.
Well, if you're using the form,
and most states have utilized this form,
they just put it in a different format, but it's all there.
This is available. It's free for download.
You can get it from the AAFP,
you can get it from American Academy of Pediatrics,
you can get it from American College of Sports Medicine,
et cetera, et cetera.
And so here are my health history questions
about the athlete,
and here are my health history questions about the family.
And then I have my physical exam.
What's my blood pressure, do I have a heart murmur?
Et cetera, et cetera.
So there are my 14-point checklist
right there on your form.
You just have to know where to look for it.
And it's not labeled as such, but it's all right there.
Okay, so our first question,
examination findings of a 17-year-old male athlete
with near syncope
and suspicion for hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
would include which of the following?
Here we go. Great.
So most of you got this.
This is a crescendo-decrescendo systolic murmur,
left sternal border, that increases with Valsalva.
So we look at cardiac sudden death in young athletes,
and so what I wanted to do
is give you a big picture here first.
What's the biggest cause of death in these individuals?
Well, they're accidents.
That's the number one cause of death.
And then what's the number two cause of death in athletes?
Cardiac related issues, okay?
And then we get suicide, so mental health issues
that are gonna follow right after that.
So this is 2023 data.
It's as hot off the press as it can be.
When we look at actual heart-related causes,
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy jumps right to the top.
So this table deserves a little bit of an explanation,
because Barry Maron's work in the first column
looked only at sudden death in athletes,
cardiac-related issues.
A third of those were due to hypertrophic cardiomyopathy,
the greatest portion
And Petex's data,
they looked at all causes of death in athletes.
And so hypertrophic cardiomyopathy,
because accidents are so high, fell in terms of percentage.
Know this: male sex, Black race, and a basketball player
is my highest risk for cardiac sudden death.
Know that, okay?
All right, and so hypertrophic cardiomyopathy,
autosomal dominant, but it has variable penetrance,
meaning I might not display all of the characteristics
right now.
They may develop over time, which is why,
because I had a screening test and an echocardiogram at 16,
I don't need to be concerned about it at 18.
I may have to consider a full workup again
because of that variable penetrance.
I might not have met the criteria at 16,
but between 16 and 18, or 19 or 20,
I may develop a full-blown hypertrophic cardiomyopathy.
So we have to pay attention to that, okay?
That's sort of a truism in this condition.
so I can't say it's been evaluated once I'm done.
If I'm suspicious of it, if I have physical findings of it,
I need to reevaluate.
Imaging or diagnosis can be done via echocardiogram.
You need to let the cardiologist know
that you're looking for this
so that they can get the correct measurements,
or cardiac MRI is the other consideration.
And management, these athletes are gonna go back to play.
Okay?
There is no indication that athletes should be withheld.
They need to be withheld
while they're getting a full evaluation.
If the athlete wants to go back to play,
they can safely go back to play with treatment,
and first line treatment's beta blocker
for these individuals.
So the whole idea of, "I have hypertrophic cardiomyopathy.
I shouldn't participate in sports,"
throw that out the window.
Once they're diagnosed and treated,
athletes can safely be returned to sports.
The key is making the diagnosis and getting them treatment.
Commotio cordis.
This is where I take a baseball or a lacrosse ball
or some kind of blunt instrument
that comes right over my precordium.
It occurs during a vulnerable part of the cardiac cycle,
and I go from ventricular tachycardia
into ventricular fibrillation, and I arrest.
This is your typical adolescent baseball pitcher
who's on the mound and gets hit with a line drive
and drops dead, so to speak.
AEDs have turned this from a fatal injury or episode
into one that is not common, but is not at all fatal.
Because these are otherwise young, healthy individuals,
we get the AED on them, they come right back.
The key is timing.
So like all things, getting the AED on them
within three minutes.
The very first description was written up
in the New England Journal, I guess maybe 20 years ago now,
and that adolescent baseball pitcher
went back to pitching, right?
So these are not common events.
Chest protectors don't work,
so that's another thing you wanna remember.
We have to talk a little bit about SARS COVID-2.
The incidence of mild care pericarditis in athletes
is low overall.
How do we evaluate this right now?
If somebody has SARS COVID-2 and they're an athlete,
particularly if they've had a fever,
and they're out for more than three days,
they're gonna get a full medical evaluation,
they're gonna get an ECG, a troponin, and an echocardiogram.
Those are normal. They can return to athletics.
If they're abnormal, then that leads to further evaluation.
The mRNA vaccine.
Now again, we have to talk about vaccine
and mild pericarditis.
So who's at risk? I'm at risk with the mRNA vaccine.
I'm a 20 to 30-year-old male,
and I'm receiving my second vaccine.
Now, we're probably getting very close
to being outside this window,
but we're gonna see it
as we have younger individuals come up,
individuals who've not been vaccinated.
But the more people who are vaccinated,
particularly if they've had two or three vaccines,
they're outside this window of risk, okay?
But that's my riskiest subgroup by far,
by far my riskiest subgroup.
20 to 30-year-old males
who are receiving their second mRNA vaccine,
they come in with shortness of breath
or palpitations or chest pain, take them seriously, okay?
Marfan syndrome, another autosomal dominant disease.
You know, arm span greater than height,
long, slender fingers, high arched palate,
the pectus excavatum, anterior chest deformities,
hyperextensible joints, these things.
Complications in athletics,
they have ascending aortic dilatation
because collagen is involved.
They also usually can have spontaneous pneumothoraces,
so they're running down the field and boom,
acutely short of breath.
And so if you are suspicious of somebody having Marfan's,
your physical exam, and I would add to that,
you're gonna just gonna go to www.marfan.org,
and you're gonna go to the systemic calculator,
and you're gonna plug in the findings.
And if you get a score of 7 or greater
then they probably have Marfan's.
Now I can consider genetic testing.
We're still working on that, so it's not streamlined.
But then I want to proceed with an echocardiogram
and a slit lamp exam, okay?
Those would be the next two tests.
Infectious mononucleosis. The risk here is splenic rupture.
I can develop hepatosplenomegaly,
but we're usually focused on the splenomegaly
that can occur with it.
So as a general rule, my athlete who has infectious mono,
they do not return to exercise or activity
for 21 days post-diagnosis,
and then they have to feel well enough to go back.
If I have splenomegaly on exam,
then they'll be continued to be held out
until that splenomegaly resolves.
Another Choosing Wisely,
avoid ordering an abdominal ultrasound routinely in athletes
with infectious mono.
You're trying to assess for hepatosplenomegaly.
Do it by physical exam.
The spleen is of variable sizes in variable people.
It's more related to my height than it is to my age,
so there's no real norm.
13 centimeters is the length that radiologists call,
13 centimeters less, it's normal.
Greater than 13 centimeters, it's enlarged.
Well, again, I take asymptomatic individuals
who are 6' or 6'5" and taller and measure 'em,
and some of 'em have 20-centimeter spleens.
They're completely fine, completely normal.
So again, there's lots of variables that go into this,
so we generally avoid that imaging.
Okay, our next question.
You're the team physician at an early preseason practice
when a 17-year-old male stumbles off the field
late in practice.
He's an overweight lineman.
He appears fatigued and he's sweating profusely.
He's clumsy and mumbling incoherently.
The trainer takes an oral temperature,
which is 102.1 degrees Fahrenheit.
The defining characteristic
distinguishing between heat exhaustion and heat stroke
is which of the following?
Absence of sweating, mental status changes,
presence of profuse sweating,
or an oral temperature greater than 102 degrees.
Okay, terrific.
So mental status changes are the defining characteristic.
So we see this as a spectrum illness, heat illness, right?
I can go from heat cramps or heat syncope
to heat exhaustion to heat stroke,
and it's really the mental status changes
that define the heat stroke,
that part of the CNS dysfunction.
And so you have your risk factors.
Those who are unacclimated.
I'm wearing a lot of clothing during practice,
it's particularly hot out, I'm overweight.
I may be trying to lose weight,
so I'm using laxatives or diuretics.
I may be using anticholinergics
because I have allergies, et cetera.
So I have all of these different medications
that can also place me at risk.
When you get your temperature,
you need to get a rectal temperature, okay?
Rectal temperature.
And when you're gonna cool an individual with this,
you're gonna cool 'em however you can.
In real life, you cool 'em as you can.
Put cold towels on 'em, strip 'em down,
throw ice packs on 'em.
Whatever you have available, you use.
But when you have a choice between lots of cooling methods
and ice water immersion, what do you do?
Ice water immersion is your best cooling technique.
Okay, our next question.
Which of the following statements is true
regarding sports related concussion?
A, physical activity is recommended
24 to 48 hours post-concussion;
B, return to sports can occur
prior to return to baseline academics;
C, physical rest is recommended until all symptoms
of the sports related concussion have resolved;
or D, the overall duration
of sports related concussion symptoms is the same
in children, adolescents, and young adults.
Okay, so the correct answer is A. A.
This has changed within the last couple of years,
so let's cover the highlights of what has changed.
Here are my risks, right? Certain sports put me at risk.
Competition as opposed to practice.
I have a higher risk in competition.
If I'm female, I'm at higher risk for having a concussion.
If I've had one concussion,
I'm at higher risk for the second.
If I've had two,
I'm at higher risk for the third, et cetera.
And then if I'm involved in an activity or a sport
where I have player to player contact,
because that's where most concussions occur.
70% occur because of player to player contact,
not player to the environment,
some inanimate object, all right?
The most common symptom they're gonna have is headache.
Otherwise, to round out the top four,
dizziness, confusion, poor concentration.
Again, Choosing Wisely.
Do not image the heads of these individuals
unless they're having focal
or progressive neurologic dysfunction.
Just because my head hurts,
just because I still get dizzy when I'm up walking around,
just because light still bothers my eyes
three weeks, four weeks,
no, there's no reason to image.
This is not a structural problem.
This is a functional problem,
and we don't have a way
to readily identify the functional deficit
outside of our history and exam.
Okay, so you wanna pay attention
to this Sport Concussion Assessment Tool.
You don't have to use it. Again, it's available online.
It's free to download and utilize.
But you need to know that this is the very best instrument
for the sideline evaluation of athletes, okay?
The 6 just means it's Version 6,
and it really hasn't changed very much from Version 1 on.
There's a Child-SCAT(6),
and that's used for children ages 5 to 12.
The SCAT is for 13 and older, okay?
Any athlete who has a concussion
does not return to play that same day, period.
And neuropsychological testing, like impact testing,
is not diagnostic,
it is adjunct in the management of concussion.
Okay, so what about the management? What do we do?
Well, we recommend physical and cognitive rest
for the first 24, maybe 48 hours.
That's it, max.
Then we follow up,
and we found that if we prescribe light activity
in that 24 to 48-hour timeframe, they do better.
They recover faster, okay?
So full rest, as we were doing before,
actually, while it might've made sense,
the symptoms were prolonged with it,
and they recover faster if we bring 'em back to activity.
That does not mean I bring 'em back
to sport and contact activity,
but that means I get 'em out and I get 'em bike riding,
or I get 'em walking,
or I get 'em out shooting some baskets.
You know, they're doing things that help them physically,
that do not exacerbate their symptoms.
That's what we're trying to do.
Again, this all has happened in the last couple years,
and it's already made it
to the Choosing Wisely campaign, okay,
to recommend early physical activity
and cognitive activity as tolerated.
Individuals have to return to their academic baseline
before they return to sport, okay?
That's a call both from our academy
and the American Academy of Pediatrics.
And then once they're ready,
once they've returned to their academic baseline,
then we start a process
of graded return to sport after that.
And we'll sort of demonstrate that in a couple of slides.
Most all athletes are gonna have symptom resolution
by 7 to 10 days post-injury,
and I gave you some risk factors
for those who might have prolonged symptoms.
And recognize that younger children take longer.
So we give younger children, 5 to 12 years of age,
four weeks to resolve,
where we give 13 and older three weeks to resolve
before we start calling their symptoms prolonged.
Okay, so this is what it really looks like.
You have your time on the x-axis.
I sustain a sports related concussion.
I have this burst of symptoms,
headache, dizziness, confusion,
and I get this burst, and then they start improving.
Within 24 to 48 hours,
I'm prescribing light physical activity,
which helps the symptoms improve more.
My next focus is on getting 'em back
to their academic baseline and getting 'em back to school.
We call this Return to Learning. So I incorporate this.
Once I have achieved this
and gotten them back to their academic baseline,
and their symptoms are continuing to improve,
now I can talk about returning to sport.
And what does that look like?
Well, it looks like now I have a stepwise progression.
Each day I allow them to do something a little bit more.
And then the key point here
is before they're gonna go back to full contact,
they're coming to see you.
You're gonna clear them to go back for full contact,
and then if they do that, gameplay, right?
But that's a key component in here,
the medical evaluation that occurs
prior to them going back to full contact.
All right, eating disorders.
You know, again, we have to mention, sadly,
you know, they're much more common
in the athletic population,
and also common among males in this population.
You have to really think about the comorbidities,
mostly mental health comorbidities, but substance use,
which is another big comorbidity in this population.
Okay, now talking about some specific injuries.
Anterior shoulder dislocation.
70% of these are anterior,
and virtually all of those are traumatic.
You're gonna be asked, "Where do you reduce them?"
I got a shoulder dislocation on the field.
Where does it get reduced? It gets reduced on the field.
You reduce it right then and there.
I know I don't have X-ray.
I know I don't feel like...
How do I do this?
The question is
where do you reduce the shoulder dislocation?
You reduce it on the field. Why?
Because it's easier, because it saves me conscious sedation,
because it saves me everything else
that goes along with the conscious sedation, all the risks.
I can reduce it immediately and easily on the field,
and so I do that.
Remember, you do a neurovascular exam of the upper extremity
before and after, okay?
Femoral acetabular impingement.
This is another you should know about.
This is relatively new in the last decade or so.
The thing to really pay attention to here,
this is not necessarily acquired.
We don't know exactly,
but there seems to be some hereditary component to this,
which then might be exacerbated by specific activities.
But we develop an abnormality of the femoral head
and/or acetabulum,
and those basically rub on each other
and they can cause pain.
The thing that's most important for you to know here
is the FAdIR test: flexion, adduction, internal rotation,
the most sensitive test for femoral acetabular impingement.
It's not FABER, it's not figure of four.
That's FADIR. This is FAdIR.
That's FABER, this is FAdIR, okay?
Flexion, abduction, internal rotation.
If I'm really concerned about this,
and I think I have an athlete who has it,
I do a lidocaine injection into the hip
and I see how they do.
And if all their symptoms go away and they're fine,
you're essentially diagnostic,
then you can go on to imaging at that point in time,
which would be an MRI.
Okay, next question.
You've been invited to present a grand rounds lecture
on "Sports Injuries in High School Athletes."
Which of the following statements
would you include in your talk?
So which of the following statements is true?
Okay, so we're split a little bit
between football having the highest injury rate
and the knee being the most commonly injured body part.
So let's look at this. A is the correct answer.
So we're gonna look at some of this data real fast.
This has been true. It is true.
I've stopped taking the data this next year in 2023-24.
We'll start compiling the data
because COVID really messed up the data.
Board's never gonna test you on messed up data.
They're testing you on common things,
being commonist if you will.
So football has the highest injury rate.
Someone or many of you're gonna ask me about cheer.
Cheerleading has the highest catastrophic injury rate,
right, subsequent paralysis, death,
severe head injury, spine injury,
but it doesn't have the highest injury rate.
It's the highest catastrophic injury rate.
When I look at competition or practice,
more of my injuries occur in competition.
It's uncontrolled, or less controlled than is practice.
When I look at the most commonly injured body parts,
head and face, far and away,
and that includes concussion, followed by ankle.
Makes sense. And then knee comes in third.
You need to know this.
The most commonly injured knee structure,
and I don't care how they ask it of you,
high school sport, college sport, intramural sport,
whatever it might be, the answer is the MCL.
It's not the ACL, it is the medial collateral ligament
is the most commonly injured knee structure.
Okay, our next question.
In a 20-year-old otherwise healthy athlete,
which physical exam test is the most sensitive maneuver
for the corresponding knee injury?
Is it A, the Thessaly test for a meniscal tear;
the anterior drawer test for the anterior cruciate ligament;
a McMurray test for the meniscal tear;
or a valgus stress test for the lateral collateral ligament?
So we're split on this, and we're gonna go over these.
I somewhat anticipated that.
It's the Thessaly test, far and away.
And if you don't know how to do it,
you should learn how to do it, okay?
What we're gonna do is just cover these.
The most sensitive test for the ACL,
you need to know this, they will ask you this.
It is the Lachman maneuver or the Lachman test.
For the posterior cruciate ligament,
it's the posterior drawer test.
For the medial collateral ligament,
it's the valgus stress test.
That's testing the medial collateral ligament.
Remember, that's the most commonly injured knee ligament
in sports.
For a meniscal tear, it's a Thessaly test,
and it can either be a single-legged Thessaly test
or a double-legged Thessaly test.
But basically I'm on bent knees about 20 to 30 degrees
and I need to pivot or swing on my knees three times, right?
Sort of a dance we do with the athlete,
and they should have pain in the area of the knee
where the meniscal tear occurred,
or where I suspect the meniscal tear is.
Okay, next question.
Which of the following statements is true
regarding ACL injuries?
A, prevention programs are ineffective
at reducing ACL injury;
B, bracing is effective in the secondary prevention
of ACL injury;
C, in high school sports, football has the highest rate
or D, surgical repair of an ACL tear
results in lower rates of knee osteoarthritis.
Okay, what did we pick? Okay, excellent.
So C is the correct answer,
and we're just gonna cover this stuff in one slide, right?
Most ACL injuries are non-contact injuries,
non-contact injuries.
In high school sports, it's football.
In collegiate sports, it's women's soccer
that have the highest rates of ACL injury.
Neuromuscular training programs or preparticipation training
is effective to reduce the rates of ACL injury
in female athletes, for sure.
Maybe in male, but the data's been a little conflicting
in male athletes.
Surgical repair's treatment of choice
if I have an unstable knee.
Knee bracing is ineffective in preventing ACL
either in the primary setting or the secondary setting.
That's why we don't use ACL braces anymore.
They've gone by the wayside, okay?
What you see a lot of times
are hinged knee braces on athletes,
but they don't have anything to do with the ACL.
They're primarily there for other reasons,
and in your football linemen on Saturdays,
they're there to protect the MCL,
because that's the most commonly injured knee ligament.
And then whether or not I develop osteoarthritis
in the knee,
this is important to be able to share with your patients.
I tore the ACL, damage has been done.
I'm at the same risk whether I get my ACL repaired or not.
I'm gonna eventually develop osteoarthritis in the knee.
The question will be how quickly is that going to occur.
The answer is, it'll be faster
in my athlete who had an ACL tear than it will be in me,
because I haven't had an ACL tear, all right?
So these are sort of vagaries that we speak in,
but that's what we convey to them.
Okay, this should be our last question.
A 26-year-old male suffers an inversion ankle injury
and ambulates to the ED for evaluation.
You find lateral ankle swelling
and tenderness over the anterior distal fibula.
The next best course of action includes...
Is it A, avoidance of the use of ankle bracing
after his injury resolves;
B, recommendations for early range of motion of the ankle;
C, avoidance of the use of nonsteroidals;
or D, radiographs of the ankle?
Okay, excellent.
So recommendation for early range of motion.
So ankle sprains, remember most common are lateral,
but the second most common are your high ankle sprains
or your syndesmotic sprains.
That's your second most common.
Early range of motion improves recovery.
Nonsteroidals are helpful.
They can reduce not only my pain,
but reduce my return to play time
so that I can get back to play more quickly.
And unlike the ACL, ankle bracing is effective
in both the primary and secondary prevention
of ankle sprains.
Someone's gonna ask me,
well, should we prescribe ankle braces
to all of our athletes before they go out and play soccer
or play field hockey or football?
And the answer is, good luck, right?
If I haven't had an ankle sprain,
do I really want to be wearing something?
And the answer is, I would tell you in my experience,
the answer is almost universally no.
Some of 'em will get taped in the training room.
That's helpful, you know?
That's gonna provide some benefit to them.
After they've had a sprain,
it's even difficult to get them to wear something
for secondary prevention,
because they like the way the cleat fits on their foot,
they like the way their shoe fits on their foot.
They don't like the inhibition that a brace affords them.
Okay, and again,
you're seeing the Ottawa Ankle Rules again, okay,
because you need to know these, and I think most of you do.
And the last thing I want to touch on here
in this sports medicine talk
is these impingement neuropathies.
Now, remember we said
the most common upper extremity impingement neuropathy is?
Carpal tunnel syndrome is the most common.
But in certain athletes, they're at high risk
for other entrapment neuropathies.
So if I'm a cyclist, I can develop handlebar neuropathy,
and that's the ulnar nerve at Guyan's canal, okay?
Because my hands are resting on the handlebars,
and I get some impingement right there.
And so what happens?
I get numbness of my fifth finger
and the ulnar aspect of my ring finger on the palmar side.
If I'm a thrower, typically baseball pitchers,
I can develop an ulnar neuropathy,
but I get numbness on the dorsal aspect of my fifth digit
and the ulnar aspect of my fourth digit,
and that's cubital tunnel syndrome,
ulnar nerve at the elbow.
And then if I'm a cyclist and my seat's a little too narrow,
I can develop a pudendal neuropathy
or a cyclist's neuropathy.
And what I want to do, and this has been asked before,
so what I want to do is I wanna widen out that seat, okay?
Take some of the pressure off of the pudendal nerve.
And then peroneal neuropathy is strictly those
who are associated with some kind of trauma.
They get hit on the outer aspect
or the lateral aspect of the knee,
or just below the knee by the fibular head,
and they can develop a peroneal neuropathy, all right?
That's it for sports medicine.
Thank you very much.
(attendees clapping)
(chiming tone)